earlier this month cbs news conducted a
poll asking americans whether they'd
rather go back in time to meet president
george washington or president abraham
lincoln and you know what i love a good
poll so i want to take a second and ask
that here hey tarik you amber if you had
the chance to travel back in time who
would you rather go meet president
washington or abraham lincoln
hmm
[Music]
see we're laughing because the correct
answer is what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you
or have you lost your damn mind
or i know you ain't talking to me i know
that's right see the people asking that
question are usually white and say
things like it would be neat to go back
in time and meet that famous person
would it you really think that people in
the 17 or 1800s are going to let my
black ass near a president
i wouldn't even be allowed in the white
house but i would be allowed to work
outside of it
the white house was built by slaves
see
time travel is fun in movies like the
terminator and terminator 2 but not the
other terminator sequels how many times
do i have to watch the arnold
schwarzenegger robot dia yeah i mean
they keep sending arnold schwarzenegger
back to fight updated versions of the
terminator without updating his system
it's like going on a race with somebody
in a ford mustang and all you have is an
old arnold schwarzenegger there's no
chance in hell
do you know how racist things were in
the 1700s
slightly worse than today
just kidding
[Music]
[Applause]
today we are dealing with so much
discrimination voter suppression
redlining police brutality that's just
to name a few and in the 17 and 1800s we
dealt with those same things black
people weren't even allowed to vote
until 1870. but don't worry everything's
fine black people can vote now
till 2024
would you rather travel back in time to
meet washington or lincoln is a messed
up question we need more context how
long would we have to stay in the past
can we bring a car because taking a
horse back would be too long and too
bumpy is it going to be painful when my
body is ripped apart and then
reassembled for the whole time travel
thing
what's the wifi situation
okay clearly we may have overthought
this but the short answer to this
question is we would never go back in
time because there are too many
negatives the even shorter answer is and
we say this with love
what the
are you talking about
that was fun yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you